in Yemen there could be a major move
toward peace in a conflict the UN calls
the world's greatest humanitarian crisis
a ceasefire is set to go into effect
tomorrow in a key port city fighting
between a saudi-led coalition and
Iranian backed rebels has pushed
millions to the brink of famine
Elizabeth Palmer was the only US network
correspondent inside Yemen and traveled
to a makeshift camp deep in rebel
territory
she left Yemen overnight and joins us
from the Jordanian capital Amman
Elizabeth good morning good morning that
ceasefire is indeed a first tentative
step toward a lasting peace in Yemen but
I can tell you it does absolutely
nothing to get adequate food and medical
care to masses of people who really need
it right now
awesome is too and so malnourished he
weighs half what he should nourish Makia
Othman Medi tries to feed him nutrition
packed pastes but he doesn't want it why
would he refuse food you can't keep it
down
I saw his muscles are so wasted Makia
tells me he can no longer walk there are
25 malnourished children and their
mothers in the Islamic clinic but many
more never make it to this small outpost
of Mercy in Yemen's rugged Northwest
this is dry land farming country but
venture off the main road and you'll
spot clusters of makeshift tents
everywhere at least 15,000 people have
fled here after fighting and Saudi
airstrikes destroyed their homes and
their lives
nurse Makia introduced us to the people
of our Buddha camp who crowded round to
show us their desperation they're so
short of food they're cooking these yes
they say even though it gives the
children diarrhea and they want to know
why isn't more help coming
the fact is eight agencies are trying to
scale up but they're facing huge
obstacles meanwhile the need grows more
acute every day nurse michaiah told me I
can offer my compassion but they need a
whole lot more than that the eight
agencies as I said are facing huge
obstacles which include the violent of
the violence the fighting of course the
fact that they're not sure where all the
people who are really in need are
there's been so much turmoil and
bureaucratic obstacles especially in
Houthi territory we were told by a
senior aide coordinator the Houthis
won't give them enough visas to get
skilled people on the ground to help
Deana seeing little awesome is a
reminder that tens of thousands of
children have already died in Yemen
Elizabeth Palmer thank you so much for
bringing us this important story